so tell me uh how did you uh come up
with the idea for the
four day work week was there like a
specific thing that happened at your
company people were burnt out you were
burnt out or you just realized this
could be an amazing way
to um attract talent who might think wow
uh i would like to have a full day we
can take a three-day ski weekend every
week
yeah i'd say over the last year we
really started doubling down on wellness
at work
so
we saw that there was a big risk with
with working from your home and not
having any degree of separation from
work in home life that people were
working too much not too little which
was our first concern right
and so we had done a lot of training and
development
and different kind of features within
our company around promoting employee
wellness
um and you know we had to coach people
to like take time off and then one day
we kind of asked the question well
instead of coaching
why don't we just institutionalize
more time off
and you know that led us to this the
concept of the four day work week
and um and they're like wow this this
could be pretty incredible
i i
i saw it and i was like you know what i
think that this
is uh particularly
important because of covid and working
at home so that's great that you're
confirming that because i too have seen
in my own uh work and then other people
who work with me that
people just wake up
obviously they don't need to take a
shower they don't need to commute
so maybe they
hit the slack room at eight or nine as
opposed to nine or ten they don't get
that half hour hour on the way to the
office to kind of prepare for work
um and they just they start going all in
on work and then i see the same people
on slack at 8 or 9 p.m
and they're just responding because they
can't go out because they're in
quarantine and maybe they've watched
everything on netflix and um yeah people
are
arguably
working too much
and it does cause mental health problems
but this could also be solved by going
back to offices so
i'm curious
what you think about the power of being
in an office with other people
as a possible solution here as well
uh we're reopening offices
i think
you know we reject the notion that you
need an office to be productive at work
obviously the world has shown us
otherwise
so for us really offices are just more
of a social benefit right they're for
building deeper social bonds with your
peers
and with your team
and so
that's really what we're designing the
offices for we're remote first which
means we're always going to act as if
we're remote but you come into the
office for camaraderie
um for maybe some brainstorming have a
lunch and meet some new people
on your team and and that kind of stuff
yeah i'm i'm thinking exactly the same
way and it's just no way to put the
genie back in the bottle because
so many of our team members have moved
and so it would be impossible to ask
them to start commuting so you basically
have to throw the gauntlet down and say
okay move back to the bay area within
you know a 45 minute commute of the
office and
you know get on board or get on cal
train and it's just not realistic uh to
then lose some of your best team members
who decided they would move to
buy a home somewhere where it's
affordable so
i think that's the only way to go
forward is to to do retreats maybe are
you thinking about bringing people in
you know like flying them in quarterly
monthly
you have you thought about that cadence
we are we're thinking about you know we
think retreats and off-sites are a big
opportunity you put a lot of intention
into doing it well they can be extremely
rewarding
and you know having a really rewarding
few days with your team where you're
super intentional about the time that
you spend with them versus just being
with them every single day in the office
you know we think that that that's the
way to go and so in addition to the
offices
we've put a lot of effort into
experimenting with different off-site
programs hopefully we'll open source
those as well
um
and uh
and you know i think the broader point
here is that we're rejecting this notion
that
you know any of the input
metrics in terms of the work you do
matter more than the output we don't
care where you work how you work how
much you work
as long as you're getting great outcomes
for the business and lifting up others
around you and doing so
then that's all that counts
which day of the week are you officially
off
we're officially off on fridays
i i had a feeling that would be the most
logical
now
um how do you handle because you
uh for people who don't know bolt does
one click checkout uh it's obviously
you're quite successful at that
this is uh a customer support driven
business
you must have five day or seven day a
week customer support you obviously have
servers up and running you can't let
everybody take off friday because
friday's a very busy day in the economy
and if your servers went down or
somebody needed customer support you
can't so what groups did you have to
adjust and say okay we're going to
have half the group or 20 percent of the
group actually work fridays and how did
you handle that
mechanically yeah i mean doing a four
day work week is not easy
um and you know what i tell other
founders is i'm not going to say that
systematizing this is easy like there's
you know you have to do hard work
thinking about all these different edge
cases and so we have
you know four days like our support
teams or service teams or on call you
know they're working four days those
weeks but you know we're we're shifting
you know some will work fridays um but
maybe they'll get their mondays off and
so there's some mechanics
uh to operationalizing this but you know
we have a lot of smart people and we're
able to figure it out
uh when you yeah and that seems like an
obvious one you know
you just have to i do you do full-time
support on the weekends too do you have
weekend customer support or does your
business just say call us monday
yeah we have weekend uh priority one
level customer support so you know we do
have to do some weekend rotations as
well perfect yeah and anybody who has a
business does that and it's fairly easy
to make those schedules and people just
pick a couple weekends a year that they
uh will will come in and make that
sacrifice and then take them stay off
pretty pretty easy to do so i guess the
next piece mechanically that i wanted to
talk about was
does that mean uh you gave you took
everybody's
vacation days holidays and pulled those
back 20
so that the number of days off is not
massively more than the work week
we left all those in
untouched
um but we get some natural discounting
because they're a bunch of fridays off
anyway
right and so
you know you get some natural
discounting there
and then i believe the way we did it was
if there's a monday off for a holiday in
that week
then it's still a four day week
you know we still just do fridays so
it's not like we're taking you know 52
weeks in the year it's not like we're
taking 52 or sorry 52 days
um out of our team it's more like 30.
um that's not the exact number but so
it's definitely a big reduction but it's
not a full 52.
[Music]